yeah uh speaking of stuff that we've
kind of done and watched recently uh
finally finished my first Final Fantasy
game oh which one yeah uh 16 I remember
when I was just like I yeah I gave up uh
I don't know if I need to finish this
and then I was like you know what I
should finish a final fantasy game how
you feel how was it can confirm I was
like I don't think I needed to finish it
oh no yeah the ending was all right it's
it was just like everything that I
thought was going to happen happened and
I was just playing it to
literally like see the climax and the
characters like closed off and I was
like eh I think I think we can agree
though right that gav is the best
character gab is [__] goated the one
who sounds like all right mate I do it
no no no that's that's s is all he's
also goated but like by the end gav is
goated like he's one of those characters
at first you're just like I don't really
care about you he's like all right M
how's it going oh how's it going you
going off for an
adventure cool I mean like the fight
yeah with 16 the fights were like
cinematically incredible like they
looked absolutely gorgeous but just just
the some of the charact like Jill was
the most boring [__] character I've
ever seen in a Final Fantasy game she
was so boring I think my favorite
experience with Final Fantasy which has
nothing to do with Final Fantasy but
just just like just picture it I'm just
going to say everything with the same
amount of context that I got I'm just
playing Final Fantasy we've literally
just finished talking about Final
Fantasy on a trash taste recording yeah
uh and I'm just like ah let's just play
a little bit more get a line message
from Joey and all I see is just out of
context oh he gay
gay and I just I just bur out I just
burst out laughing okay so there's
there's a scene one of the characters uh
he's like the the king of one of the the
oh he's like the prince of one of the
kingdoms uh that you you he's like one
of the boss fights basically um and you
know very Progressive of Square Enix uh
he he's he's a gay character right and
but it the way that they reveal that he
is a gay character just comes so
suddenly where like you're kind of
watching him talk and you're like all
right yeah he's you know just like a
typical blond haad blue-eyed PR typical
Final Fantasy typical Final Fantasy like
Prince character and then he just starts
making out with his God and I'm just
like whoa he and I just texted G in all
caps oh he gay gay I I got what he was
cuz I remember playing it with Sydney uh
like the like the first like beginning
bit and and Sydney was like he's
definitely gay and I was like Sydney we
we're like this is the first scene I was
like no he gay and then like then
afterwards like I get the message from
Joey being like oh he gay gay
so so they they they obviously like they
did the energy well you know to be like
like oh is it something that going to
like kind of like tease is it going to
be the usual anime thing where it's just
like you know are they best friends or
are they
like is he European or is he gay we'll
never know they they they've went full
oh he gay gay does he know yeah but I
think 16 was just in the grandest scheme
of all the Final Fantasy games I thought
it was all right it epitomizes every
reason why I don't I very rarely finish
AJ RPG where it's just you have this the
ending is
important yeah but the ending is
normally some of his Parts you know it's
probably I mean it didn't do anything
that surprised me and a lot of the
interesting and more climactic uh kind
of like interesting moments for me uh
came about 2/3 or like the last quarter
of the way through the story where I I'm
not going to spoil what my favorite
parts of this game was but there is a
climactic moment and a climactic boss
battle and that I I remember
experiencing that and I was like this is
where the game has peaked like in my
mind I was like I can't see a moment
that has that will eclipse the moment
that this has just presented me and I
was just like after that I was kind of
like I kind of just feel like I'm just
ticking off the box now are you are you
talking about the Bahamut Fight yes yeah
that is easily the best part of that
game yeah not not just the fight itself
but just the the lead up to that the
moment the the moment the payoff with
all the characters as well I was just
like all right this like I I agree with
that that was definitely the peak of
that game yeah yeah I was like this is
this is this is [__] Peak and then I
was just like everything else just feels
like I'm just ticking off the boxes to
make sure they close it off and then it
continued for another 20 hours you know
and just kind of fizzled out so yeah
that was
unfortunate oh there's more oh [__] all
right there was also a scene on the
beach wa I was just
like I agree that was also Peak what is
the scene it's the scene basically where
spoilers for 16 it's basically the scene
where Clive our main character and Jill
the main love interest they finally kiss
right um and but to give context they're
naked on this beach for about a full
five minutes and I'm just like cuz they
just are I can't remember the context
but I remember them being naked and like
Jill talking about her [__]
motivations and being like a good like I
I'll be with you to the yank live and
I'm just like just [__] do it already
just [__] just [__] right now just do it
just do it just stop [__] teasing me
me c is there just sitting there
listening bricked up the [__] it's just
like can you shut up I really want to
make out with you right now yeah I
remember when it finally happened I like
threw my control I was just like oh
finally oh it happened oh my God than
God yeah it didn't make the ending any
better though but yeah yeah it was it I
I thought it was a an all right Final
Fantasy game when you played uh six no
eight did you like did you have that
same feeling where you're just like
about like the last third you're like
okay I'm just like ticking off the boxes
now I think has a more interesting yeah
I actually really like the ending to
eight really I thought it already cool
ending uh that that it was almost in the
Middle where it kind of lost me actually
the start really the start was AC often
I find yeah the start of long jrpgs are
the hardest to get into it's like you
you if you're a jrpg person you're so
willing to jump into that yeah but if
you're not I feel like that is the first
20 hours is where you're just that's
crazy to say the first 20 hours but like
that's where you're going to lose a lot
of people because it's like that you
have to really give this world a lot of
like hope that it's going to pay off do
you think that's a valid
argument um for just any piece of media
it gets good after no [__] no X hours no
bro JoJo be like
schoy has a 4-Hour film and we're
discussing whether that's too long so to
go to someone and be like hey you know
it gets good 20 hours in that's
psychotic to say that it shouldn't be it
shouldn't be like
that JoJo would be like Jojo I think
JoJo Just yeah JoJo kind of it's a tough
one it's really tough and I think Jo you
know I know you don't want to true just
kind of the first part is the weakest
and that's what makes it by far the
hardest to get into totally um which is
a shame really it is the jrpg of anime
it kind of is and it's really bad cuz
it's like it's also hasn't quite found
its like I feel like it's kind of charm
in season one yet it's still trying to
figure out how dumb to go with it oh
totally no cuz I was I was thinking
about this cuz I was uh like looking for
another game to get into uh and I was
like Starfield I think maybe seems kind
of up my alley it's like sci-fi and I
was looking up like reviews and stuff
and people like there was like quite a
few articles that were like you know the
first 12 hours were pretty like mediocre
but then it gets good that's that's fine
and I'm
like
huh huh that's a no from me dog yeah
that's that's that's a that's a big
that's a full-time job to start
appreciating something I'm I'm like in
two minds about this right cuz I I I do
think that you know there is an argument
to be made that it gets good after X
hours um is like a valid argument
because there there's like a certain
argument where there are some stories
like for example one piece where the
scale is so [__] Grand that I think
the like I think the it takes this many
manga chapters or this many volumes um
to get into like the world of one piece
I I like I honestly think that is
Justified just with the scale of the
story being told in one piece and then
there is other things where I think it's
kind of like a stockhome syndrome where
you're in this game or you're in this
like story for so long that you're like
yeah I think is good but that's because
I spent this many hours playing it would
you would you say then that that like
say JoJo fits into the one piece side of
the mold or the other side cuz it's kind
of in the middle in my opinion it's a
bit of both it's like yeah it's a very
grandio Story I mean it's been going
longer than one piece technically
speaking Yeah but it's also like it's
not it's also not as consistent as one
pieces as well so it's like it's hard to
say cuz you know a lot of people will
say like oh yeah yeah just you know just
don't worry after season after part one
it'll it'll get it part two is good part
two is good you know what let's hard to
get people into you know what you know
what I think it's the Stockholm syndrome
I I I'm I'm thinking about it and I'm
thinking why okay Jo fans don't want to
admit it I I I didn't even want to say
like part one or whatever I was thinking
like part three part three yeah where
the reason I liked part three was just
because I love the feeling of like just
going on a trip with the boys right and
I just I just remember thinking man this
was really dragged out yeah I think part
three was worse than part one yeah but
holy [__] like did I did I value my time
with the boys just because I was forced
to sit down and see the entire Journey
because you knew that if you got through
that then part four and five would be
next which are just goed yeah so it's
like I'll just stick through it cuz I
know I'm going to get to the good stuff
I don't think I would have I just
happened to have it happened to be able
to watch it I had no internet and I
think that's the only reason I watched
it is cuz I just happened to I was the
only thing I could watch yeah and
because season 3 was so long and I don't
think I could go back and rewatch it I I
just go back and rewatch the last five
episodes I'm like yeah this is good yeah
yeah but uh yeah I think it's it's
definitely very very tough to get into
it for Jojo fans sorry Joo sorry JoJo
fans I do love it though obviously but
it is just so hard to get people to
watch it yeah it's it's definitely to
justify not that you should have to
justify getting everyone into a certain
show no if you don't like Jojo that's
fine yeah